plus 17,7 pour cent pour les
investissements - 3 9 % pour les
dépenses de fonctionnement la droite
tient à marquer sa direction pour ce
deuxième budget de l'ère valérie
pécresse
dans le détail les investissements dans
les transports s'élève cette année à 738
millions d'euros une hausse de 23% par
rapport en 2016
même constat pour le développement
économique ou encore les lycées avec
dans ce dernier secteur une hausse des
investissements de 26%
on a plusieurs dizaines de lycées en
ile-de-france qui sont dans une
situation de vétusté très préoccupante
et donc il faut trouver pour chacun
d'entre eux des solutions et puis par
ailleurs les enfants du baby boom de
2000 2001 2002 2003 arrive aujourd'hui
au lycée et donc on va avoir besoin de
créer dix mille places supplémentaires
sinon les enfants seront accueillis dans
des algeco au total c'est près de 2
milliards d'euros d'investissements qui
sont prévues cette année alors que les
ressources de la région continuent de
baisser avec notamment le désengagement
de l'état
- 75 millions d'euros en 2017 pour y
faire face la région taille par exemple
dans les dépenses de fonctionnement ou
fait appel au fonds européen
nous avons obtenu parce que nous sommes
allés négocier pied à pied
180 millions d'euros de crédits
européens et je tiens d'ailleurs à
saluer l'action de pierre lequiller ya
deux ans la région avaient été chercher
20 millions d'euros de crédits européens
cette année ce sera 180 millions d'euros
et c'est crédible on va pouvoir les
dépensés pour les franciliens le budget
2010 est de la région ile-de-france sera
soumis au vote des 209 élus le 23
janvier prochain